Hello everybody, Dr. Carter's again, this presentation is really going to be about understanding
the progression of self care.
How we're going to put these modules together, laid it out in some other videos.
We just want to talk about this first piece here.
I really want you to understand that I have this picture of somebody studying because that's
really what you're going to be doing.
You have to educate yourself.
I'm really big into learning.
You've got to learn how to take care of yourself.
I've said this a million times.
We're moving into an era of time where you might not be able to go to a doctor anymore.
You might have to be able to take care of yourself.
You have to know these things.
Ignorance is not bliss.
Ignorance just leads to misery.
So we are not to be ignorant, you know, I cannot over stress that.
So that flow of proper self care really, it's starting at the beginning, educating ourselves.
So we're going to flood you with information as much information as I possibly can, and
remember, this is a living course.
I'm going to be adding information all the time.
So educating ourselves, the key to understanding really autoimmune issues, again, I emphasize this,
it's understanding that loss of self-tolerance.
So we have all sorts of attacks on us, all right, from physical pollutants to chemical
things, to stressors to spiritual things, to good mistakes, our government is attacking
us, and our immune system could go haywire.
You already have antibodies to self-tissue, you feel the effects of it.
How many people that didn't know they have an autoimmune disease?
Maybe this whole thing, it's going on the last few years, they've had all sorts of flares,
all sorts of problems, even deaths, and it wasn't because of the virus, or it wasn't even
because of a shot that they took, because they didn't experience those things.
But it was because of all the stressors, all the things that were going out of their body,
they already had antibodies to self-tissue their body.
Their immune system was already in a state of dysregulation, and they just could not handle
it, their self-tolerance, which was not there at all, and they crashed hard, and some people
even died because of that.
So the more that we can understand that self-tolerance, the better.
And through this whole process, I've said this over and over again, it's not a matter of
being cured of an autoimmune disease, it's a matter of understanding how to balance it
and how to manage it, so that your lows today are just not going to be as low as they
were a few months ago, we're just getting better and better at kind of melding that out.
But you are going to have flare ups, you are going to have relapses.
That's part of the process, you have to understand that.
We just want your bad days today, or we could say your good days today are going to be like
your maybe listed as your bad days in three months, meaning that you're just going to be moving
up the hill.
You're still going to have these undulations, you're still going to have these highs and
lows, but we want your highs to be higher and your lows to be at a scale that aren't as
deep as they are right now.
That's the idea of going through remissions and relapses and you're just slowly moving
towards getting better.
But this first section is about learning.
The Bible is very clear to study to show yourself approved to God, a workman that needeth not
be ashamed.
Of course, this is talking about biblical things to be able to answer in season and out about
the mercy and the grace that God has showed unto you.
But Paul said, 19 times throughout scripture, to the brethren, I wish that you do not be
ignorant in this thing.
Now he's not just talking about spiritual things.
We can't separate our spiritual life from our physical life from our emotional life.
We are one being that God created and they're all tied together.
So when God's talking to us about not being ignorant that we're supposed to study to
show ourselves approved, he gave us a brain for a reason.
So yes, I understand some people are more well and down and some people can catch things
quicker.
But don't sell yourself short.
If you can learn simple things, I'm trying to break down complex things into simple things
for you.
You're listening to this video, you're highly intelligent.
So don't sell yourself short.
Continue to study and know that God is going to work through this and in you to help you
heal and help you understand your disease or your loved ones disease so that you can best
heal them.
And regardless of whether we completely are cured or not, we're going to be able to manage
it better.
We're going to be able to get through it better and we're going to have a better attitude
through it.
I understand that God has a purpose in it and he can be still glorified in my disease.
That's the key.
But I do want you to have mercy on yourself and receive the mercy that God wants to give
you.
Matthew 5.7 says, God blesses those who are merciful for they will be shown mercy.
But we have to receive that mercy and that grace from God.
You can't beat yourself up because you're not feeling good.
You can't beat yourself up because you don't know everything or because you made mistakes
in life or because you, you know, you know, worked where you should be or should it aren't
where you think you should be.
Don't beat yourself up.
Learn to be grateful every day and just ask for God's mercy and ask for God's grace and
let yourself experience that.
That's the key in understanding and educating is that God takes you through a progression
and it teaches you day by day and his mercies are new every day.
So today we screwed up tomorrow is a new day.
It is mercy is new tomorrow fresh and for us to experience will just just experience it.
Let yourself experience it.
Alright, that's your first steps.
Your first lessons.
Thanks.
I love you and God loves you too.
Bye-bye.